people say to me well do spirits look at
you and your naked in the shower or if
i'm having sex is my dead father seeing
me having sex you know you get questions
like that
[Music]
sometimes people come to the funeral
dress like they're going to the club
love it
where they look like liquid people
walking down the hallway and i was like
oh my gosh is that my unborn son
[Music]
i think our conversation is going to be
really interesting today since we're
making truffles i'm a little bit more
excited
make an assumption about me
that you like dead people
um
yeah well i like them better than living
ones
i don't know if they can hear me but i
try to talk to them anyway i was driving
a woman to her funeral and i felt like
she would like some country gospel so i
put on dolly parton and alan jackson i
love that yeah i remember thinking i
hope she likes this
my assumption was that you are
constantly hearing voices
constantly depends on if i'm checking in
or out there's always someone with me
that's probably a dead person what's
really hard is when you're on a date and
then someone's family member shows up on
the date that's not the funnest thing i
could see that as a buzzkill
this is
weirdly satisfying
what led you to your current profession
both my parents died kind of young
i was confronted with death and i
thought
how can i channel this in a healthy
positive way it was kind of my mission
to help people
my mom looked really bad like her
embalming was really bad and so i really
wanted to be good at this and make sure
other people's loved ones look good
i started out as a mental health
therapist my
mentor was like you know you're really
good at reading people but i didn't know
that i was reading them i just thought i
was a really good therapist
i called a medium and she says well you
know you're kind of a medium right i was
like yeah probably and within a few
months i started seeing spirits like
really intensely it's like she triggered
me there's actually like a hogwarts and
that we go to to train believe it or not
yeah
way cooler than funerals i know right
since the feelings goes in there and
then we mix
what do you believe happens after
someone dies
oh
well i i guess i know physically what
happens to them uh-huh people ask me do
spirits follow you around and i feel
like they stay where they they are and
i'm caring for their shell ah i see them
obviously walking around casually
um they're right here with us actually
all the time
they're just in a different vibrational
pattern
so their frequency is different than
ours when you release from the body your
frequency raises and then you are
in your consciousness of love and some
people are doing their hobbies and some
people are hanging out and some people
are still learning you know with people
that maybe died with depression or
you know of tragic means um i often see
them in like a spiritual hospital and
they're kind of like in recovery and
they're getting supported you know by
angels and loved ones who are helping
them kind of in their process of
evolving to be in another state i want
to be a flashy ghost
yeah i mean sometimes i've seen people
who come kind of like the matrix where
they look like liquid people walking
down the hallway and that kind of
freaked me out when i was staging my
house and those little boy like started
running down and i was like oh my gosh
is that my unborn son and he was like a
liquid person and i was like this is
freaky
oh it says put it in a ziploc bag
this is cool
in what ways is your career
misunderstood
that's a good one there's a lot of
controversy
that i'm of the devil or that i
you know summons devils or a con artist
those are kind of things when really i'm
just a servant of love i i think what i
do is
a miracle to be right honest
people
think that
we are really sad all the time or that
our job is sad but you know
we we're celebrating lives
and so it doesn't always have to be sad
and we do have a bit of you know morbid
humor
at work that helps you you have to be
yeah it helps us get through it's
difficult job so it helps us get through
get through the day
do you have like a playlist like when
you're doing the whole body work that
you have that gets you in the group to
like yeah what you do what's your song
like the
funeral embalming song what is that song
for you uh beyonce's lemonade oh you're
playing lemonade when you're you're
you're literally working over my body
yeah it's getting empowered wow yeah
it's like cooking everybody has a
different recipe
all right this is definitely getting
there i don't know how melted we need to
make it but
what is your take on reincarnation
ah i'll let you take that one no
reincarnation uh that was too yours i
don't
i don't know
my family's from india you know people
in india believe in reincarnation but i
just don't know there's so much unknown
well i'm a team reincarnation okay
so
i absolutely believe really more in past
lives i really believe like
our spiritual energy just continues
infinitely with no stop and no beginning
and so we just put on the new outfit of
the new body and the new clothes that
could be a different gender could be a
different race it could be a different
socio-economic group can we come back as
another species you know that's
debatable for me personally i do believe
our animals do come back and find us
yeah and so i believe that we do find
soul family soul members animal
non-animal and we kind of come back and
meet each other over and over again for
purposes of growth and learning yeah i
desperately want to come back as a cat
you would be a cool cadbury for sure
meow
i actually had a
90 year old woman who was so beautiful i
had a lot of fun making her look nice
and then her family said she looked too
sexy oh wow well i will tell you
sometimes people are characters when
they pass i mean i had this one guy
confess that he was porn star
and um he confessed that and showed his
you know you know what to
confirm you know his talent he sat on my
lap and almost gave me like a lap dance
it was a complete thing and i'm talking
to the girl who used to be his fiance
who said that's absolutely him it's
totally true i was very embarrassed he
kind of made out with me a little bit in
spirit but it was it was entertaining i
mean he brought he brought me so much
fun so like you know it's the good the
personality spicy spirit
he was he was definitely spicy sometimes
people come to the funeral dress like
they're going to the club
love it um
people
don't really come to me with the fear of
dying
some people are nervous about me seeing
them naked regardless of what what they
give me i always put a pair of socks
because you feel like their feet are
cold
i had a
beautiful woman that lost her hair and
eyebrows because of chemotherapy
and i actually used her own hair to cut
and make eyebrows for her that's amazing
yeah and i was really proud of that we
do
have something of a tummy tuck when for
everybody gets a little tummy tuck yeah
because we remove cavity fluid and so
it's the tummy just goes right down and
we use fillers
to to kind of like fillers like you can
get like your lips plumped or like your
cheeks yeah yeah
i do that all the time in fact that's
one of my favorite things because that's
a
bit of a skill to are you like a
juvederm or like a radiesse
[Music]
interesting people say to me well do
spirits look at you and your naked in
the shower or if i'm having sex is my
dead father seeing me having sex you
know you get questions like that they
just see us as light
so we're just light to them so they
don't see us and like we don't see them
in their form they don't see us in our
physical form right was your assumption
about me
correct
yes actually
yeah i i had i felt my assumption was
that we would have a really illuminating
conversation and it has been you know my
assumption about you is that you would
be just open and down for anything
because you obviously deal with the most
vulnerable experience that someone could
possibly experience in life okay cheers
cheers to
deep and dark conversations
and to our friends around us because
literally the life and death of us just
white chocolate it's absolutely right
[Music]